a vote by the British people to leave
the EU would be a huge and historic
shock here's what to expect in the
aftermath the unprecedented occasion of
a nation leaving the biggest union of
countries in history may result in an
emergency meeting of EU top brass expect
pro Europe France and Germany to do
everything to show the alliance remains
United while all this is happening there
could be wild swings in the British
currency lively market reactions and
even a crash currency markets are said
not to have priced in the UK's exit one
thing we know for sure is that just four
days after the result all 28 EU leaders
will hold a summit
they'll be fearful in action could give
momentum to populist groups that came to
gain power following the UK's exit a
general election is due to take place in
Spain almost immediately European
leaders will have to look strong to
prevent anti-eu feeling from other
countries it's here UK Prime Minister
David Cameron will likely have to
trigger a score 50 the never used before
law that ejects a country from the EU
this will be a crucial moment in shaping
the UK's relationship with the EU in the
years to come into the first hundred
days could there be a domino effect of
discontent Holland Germany and France
all have national elections coming up
this could impact how they negotiate
with the UK and could weaken britain's
hand we may well see a new figure
leading the UK - after taking Britain
out of the EU David Cameron may lose the
support of his party and he may be
replaced by the bookmakers favorite and
strong euro skeptic Boris Johnson
whoever it is the new British leader
could face immediate pressure from
another referendum in Scotland a country
within the UK that is typically pro
Europe in the long term Britain has two
whole years to negotiate an exit some
talks could take much longer and the UK
would lose some influence we can expect
a chaotic and drawn-out drama before we
really know what the new Britain will
look like